hi this is John Delaney with Ramsey
Network it is awesome to see you and
hope everybody's doing well and staying
together today we're gonna talk about
relational health and mental health
during the great disconnection right
when we're all being told to stay inside
we're all stuck where we are and we're
trying to figure out how to navigate the
world by ourselves in our one-bedroom
apartment so we're having to navigate
the world with two people working from
home kids everywhere or single-parent
homes and kids everywhere and just
figured it all out right so I'm gonna
talk about relational health and mental
health today first how to stay and
healthy helped us avoid getting this
coronavirus it is super clear stress
lack of sleep and disconnection make us
more likely to get sick okay stress
disconnection and lack of sleep so it's
important for us to try to minimize
stress as much as possible and I know
that sounds ridiculous when you're stuck
inside your house right and you've got
kids everywhere you're lonely may have
been one of the millions of people who
just got laid off right so it sounds
kind of trite and lame just to be like
hey keep your stress down right there
are things we can do and we start with
getting connected okay we are designed
to be connected to one another we're
designed to be in connection with
friends or community or romantic
partners it were designed for connection
so first and foremost is fine ways to
get to connected and if you're like me
proactively getting connected is weird
it can be uncomfortable but I'm telling
you is you have to do it this is
non-negotiable you gotta find people you
can get connected with that could be
folks that you used to work with that
could be folks that used to be roommates
in college I don't care where you're
getting connected but get connected and
by the way don't be one of those weird
people in the next door app that's just
complaining about everything do positive
connections right get involved with a
local church stream something but find
ways to get connected even if it's
writing letters to folks and and you're
waiting to connect it back chest get
connected the second thing is gotta work
on getting some sleep okay that means at
about 8:30 9:30 10:30 about an hour out
when you go to bed turn the computers
off turn the screens off and start a
routine for going to sleep right that
may mean turning the lights down in your
house reading a little bit saving your
place where you go to bed like saving
your bed just for sleeping right but get
a good sleep routine and start working
on getting good sleep okay third
reducing your stress is gonna be about
making sure you've got
the four walls covered right making sure
your transportation is covered your
house is covered your food is covered
and that your utilities are covered if
you have to file for unemployment if you
got to do so many things I want you to
go Dave Ramsey comm / hope they got all
the information you need about the four
walls about your finances but make sure
those things are covered and you're
gonna feel yourself once you know you
got a place to sleep you got food on
your table at the people that you care
about are taken care of and you can get
to and from the places you need to go
your stress just goes down right and
then you can start focusing on sleepster
focus on connection things like that by
the way I talked about this on the
message of hope keep sitting funny memes
you got to keep soon if any memes number
one I need them but laughing is good for
your soul okay laughs feels good laughs
is good for your soul next thing if you
were like me dude I'm mainlining gummy
candy I just wake up everyday I used to
be really disciplined about my diet I
was really disciplined about working out
all the time
I've got folks in my life who are
drinking way more than they normally do
I am eating more candy more junk food
man every day I get home like hey you're
on order pizza hey on order pizza I've
had more burritos in the last I've had
more burritos today then I've had in the
last calendar you're not really my mom
calls it the cove at 19 right that we're
gonna all have at 19 pounds when this
thing is all over and they're gonna be
facing a diabetes epidemic on the back
of this do the best you can to control
your diet eat well exercise where you
can right and really be careful about
drinking too much in this time the more
you're alone the more you're stressed
the easier eating and drinking start to
compress that stuff but it just numbs it
out man and when you start numbing it
out you got a price to pay later on down
the road and then I'm getting this
question how do we exercise when we're
stuck inside I want to encourage you to
get online
there are bajillion how to workout at
homes bodyweight exercises how to go for
walks outside and exercise you may see
me going for walks and then I'll drop
down and do 25 or 50 pushups so then
I'll go for a further walk down the way
and I'll benchpress my kid on the side
of the road I'm doing whatever I can I
know I look weird my kid my nine year
old or 10 year old just turned 10 the
other day Hank told me I was carrying my
kids down a busy street in a wheel
barrel as a part of a workout for me as
part of a fun thing for them and my son
looked at me and he's like yeah this is
super embarrassing right now and I was
like I don't even care you know that
your dad is this his house is gonna be
for a while
cuz we're locked in our house and I
can't go to the gym so whether it's
taking your kids down the street in a
wheelbarrow whether it's doing workouts
at home if you're in some of these major
cities that have locked down orders you
can't even go outside get online find a
workout program and just stick with it
and stick with it and stick with it
exercise is a good way to clear your
head clear your heart and clear your
mind it helps you sleep at night it can
put you on a trajectory towards eating
better and it's just good for your soul
right and then finally with relational
health we talked a lot about being
connected you can be disconnected inside
of a crowded house and if you're like me
when I get stressed I tend to withdraw
and I tend to pull away oh my wife gets
stressed she tends to start making lists
and what we can do if we're not careful
has become lonely in a crowded space or
if you are stuck in a one-bedroom
apartment and you don't even have pets
this isn't lonely anymore this is every
alarm they have is going off this is
pathological this is scary loneliness
right reach out to people that you care
about but be intentional about
connecting and I say this all the time
but communication is not connection like
in my house for me and my wife are
working on home schooling and we were
working on what dinner is gonna look
like and how can we split up the chores
and I got to go pick up the stuff from
the store and she's got to do that
that's communication that is not
connection communication is what we do
at work we transmit information
connection is sitting down holding
somebody's hands look them in the eye
and said how are you doing right or if
you're by yourself that is facetiming
somebody that you haven't talked to in a
while and looking them in the eye the
best you can is in how are you doing or
that's writing a letter to say I miss
you and here's why you're important to
me so that somebody can get that letter
and hold it and touch it in as tangible
and it makes an impact on their hearts
in their mind make sure you're
connecting tonight a good friend and
musician here in Nashville and eaglehorn
is doing a 90's country concert on
facebook live or Instagram life or one
of the Internet's things my wife and I
she loves 90s country I'd rather set
myself on fire but we're doing it cuz
we're connecting tonight and we're gonna
watch this virtual concert together
that's connection not communication
right so make sure you connect connect
to connect honor those relationships so
during this moment I'm calling the great
disconnection where the best things we
can do for our neighbors we're told is
to stay away from them right make sure
that you find ways to move into exercise
but you can go outside and walk or
you're doing one of these in-house
online
I'm sorry find a way to keep keep moving
make sure you are sleeping make sure
you're doing the things you can do that
you can control to lower your stress and
make sure you're taking care of those
relationships you're connecting
connecting connecting not just
transmitting information and
communicating but that you're connecting
stay well and I'll see you soon
take care